that understand me you [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] kidding me or what welcome
to another look at this guy
this is Joey Diaz on his eighth day
[ __ ] iron beard the rack from Havana
Cuba [ __ ] but who the [ __ ] are you
kidding
uncle Joey greetings [ __ ] up this
you're alive you've made it we got a
bunch of we got a great show for you
tonight
the star isn't throwing Heat we got the
noose our stars from stars 125
milligrams we got three of these we got
two of those and we got the ship that
killed this Monday night 200 milligrams
Cathy [ __ ] taffy I got my leg the
shirt I don't respect for Kobe Bryant
[ __ ]
something like that who gives a [ __ ] the
smoke and refit get over here Lee
take this [ __ ] reefer we're gonna
need some [ __ ] stars right now we're
gonna play the star game I don't know
first weep these caffeine Taffy's these
goes down nice and [ __ ] delicious how
are you beautiful people I've missed you
big only nice there's a big one [ __ ]
we don't [ __ ] around here in the House
of Pain [ __ ] huh we came to get
down oh yeah nice crack you will see the
[ __ ] devil boys your we got another
750 milligrams here we're gonna chop
those up too way
I might not one reason to my forehead
much as they got a make they gotta make
a star that you put like on you and your
shoulder like scotch tape and it goes
into your system all back look at right
here man you know how we do we mix them
up because I only look at that star that
be hmm just like mama used to make
[ __ ] know Sam was good to see
him I'm happy you came on to swing with
us tonight we still got three [ __ ]
scars of debt left these are three doses
125 milligrams per we already got 325 in
this will go on floor what a dick let's
go for two more hundred to see that I
didn't sleep too good tonight this
[ __ ] no steroids you know why ten
o'clock at night this weed ain't working
all that will take me to a different
planet oh yeah what's happenin the
Lakers Kobe Bryant out of respect do I
give a [ __ ] not really but I live in LA
and I got a support in somewhere another
you know something and here we go
I got some funny all-stars for your
honest [ __ ] Lisa asked looking good but
as usual will you hear I'm with you
you're with me they're with us
[ __ ] I'm thinking of a good
album to play tonight
it's been tough lately you know I've got
two new albums from people sent me so
nouns but I gotta get some [ __ ] I gotta
kick it up cool but you know I'm saying
I gotta take it with a new one
don't mind me would you smoke on a
number of that wait for guests
she says she's stuck in traffic I don't
give a [ __ ] we're gonna start the party
without it cuz that's what we do the
party don't wait you know saying the
party is like life it don't wait for
nobody [ __ ] a sandwich was
delicious tonight we stopped by pornos
and Burbank does a little cup of Cuban
appetizers for our guests they could be
[ __ ] you know for sure obviously she's
gonna be late oh [ __ ] a little [ __ ]
salsa music for you [ __ ] here
I just bought in a [ __ ] almond milk
and fruit smoothie I made this morning
unbeliev will you ever have a nominal
guru slowly what comes out of here let's
say you have the food smoothie about
7:00 a.m. 6:45 what starts coming out of
the air so about 12:40 is [ __ ]
tremendous people look at themselves
because forget exit give a [ __ ] if
somebody gets anxiety that's when you
know that's a good [ __ ] [ __ ] what it
smells like their fathers where they're
[ __ ] the grooviest molester but
whoever the [ __ ] bought it that way so
anyway we are you're with me I'm with
Jews and they're with us 45 take top all
as well and here you are we up with Joe
is you know we never miss a [ __ ] date
you always would you just as you think
woman but not always on the tool bunch
and I tell me where did you guys quit
you don't put on YouTube no more you
don't even listen cuz if you're [ __ ]
list and you know we were on Vimeo
so coming up on YouTube but we got
suspenders that were Street check it out
because they all have pages
what do you know about this will be
eight o'clock whether you show up you
don't comment it's me with you
oh [ __ ] thank you for [ __ ] watching
this is not happening last night the
response is overwhelming to the bottom
of my heart you know I love you
[ __ ] like family [ __ ] you know
why cuz we are [ __ ] families we take
this from you that I'll be smoking dope
all night
so we just need the other spawn to see
what happens take my chances with his
name if I have to call Damon tough to
come over the campus I'm just least
going down the Cosby [ __ ] Spanish New
York City stop funny all-stars
let's go one more please here we go I
don't care what nationality you are this
is as good as it gets you wanna come to
the [ __ ] Ricans in the cubed ready to
review backs against a few Dominicans
and I star at that I got a call payment
down the commode with the camera the
leads going deep into the murky waters
or the underworld
yeah night we ate we ate more than fifty
milligrams of those buffing gooey things
up
in a corner - yes 125 a big sweet tooth
that's 250 into the cavity yes of going
for and 250 it's for 50 120 following
three of these yeah yeah
so I got a deal with so we'll switch
this law out of respect for the 19
[ __ ] stars we might as well do a
[ __ ] I'm very stuck on Pink Floyd
like different times of the year you
know sometimes it's paint Floyd
sometimes Epling sometimes just the
Black Keys I get stuck on different [ __ ]
is it random or is it like around a
certain time a year you let this keep
you in some very random very very you
know I can't believe that phone
continuity or at least similar one is on
YouTube my novel quoi you know exam this
is always been one of my favorite you're
gonna put the other side on tonight I'm
gonna put the not the dog side but the
mother [ __ ] sheep side how's that cuz
I know your mother [ __ ] rubbish
who sure you'll be famous you'll be
feeling this about 10 minutes this is
time activated [ __ ] THC in
stars and his refrain no pushover either
this is direct and [ __ ] Sun Sun every
but when I thank my buddy who left me
three our packs of those stars I don't
know what the [ __ ] he wrote it down I
don't know what I did with it but I want
to thank you know who the [ __ ] y'all get
from the podcast does with me well he
doesn't these [ __ ] jet down not well
he does whether these Gentiles do the
Starbucks they go through the window
they say pay for the guy behind me this
guy every time I go in these history
stuff get your name and let you know
that we love you we get your back oh
[ __ ] it's like this this is it as as
simple as it guess there's no explosives
there's no dramas gonna be lying here
with half facts that don't exist there's
a straight-up [ __ ] men talking dick
let's say this I am beer you here you to
live with us you get [ __ ] to dump
right on your own you get tuned up at
home I hope you [ __ ] get oh man this
corner of death over here
there you go look at me looking like
Tony La Bamba on a hundred and fifty
cents and bas sugah Boulevard don't ask
I'm breathing again I'm on the steroids
I got to spray and take four pills get
two more days then three pills for four
days and put pills for two days don't
have the pill that I'm often go back to
the doctor they decide well they're
gonna [ __ ] fix this cocaine not
knowing I'm Neela it's kaput it just to
put it in this family
hey I'm getting what I deserve ain't
crying nobody that's why I got insurance
to rebuild the damage we did the last 53
years come suckers and if that don't fix
it maybe these green [ __ ] this closet
better face it there's one standard and
it's like the ugly chick at the prom
she's just sitting against the table
wait for somebody to understand Oh
- leave Lux [ __ ] sloshed who doesn't
feel fine again for this for Kazama do
for you
this shoe let's mix strawberries on
little berries cup of cherries I had a D
scene of his [ __ ] malicious but the ship
comes right Ally [ __ ] when you threw
all these people vegan it up you do the
same thing with [ __ ] oranges see what
comes out of your stomach
it's the Dave Gilmour is that [ __ ] the
promise she pops up this year here we
are
I know what this time another boat can't
be mr. Faust like this is hearing pigs I
understand [ __ ] goods
and we'll get this podcast done I clean
my family you know why I wanna get my
lungs like a [ __ ] calamari oh that's
it
in your madness of the [ __ ] sound
like that you stick your thing and that
monkey work the monkey off my ass or
judgment I'll pull them in you be there
every night oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] at
home they're gonna jumping out a window
if you're 13 don't do this
stay in school [ __ ] for the
capital school do it the [ __ ] you need
to do Vegeta
he's [ __ ] admitted to it you take
your chances you take the fight you get
a [ __ ] and then whatever who knows
they don't even Japanese people throw
nothing slow
the Joey here would you connect on a
[ __ ] boring ass Wednesday night ain't
been no better at least I make insane I
mean I'm no light a [ __ ] ray here
either
I ain't changing literally he's sitting
there waiting for me to put all
[ __ ] and into his [ __ ] nostril
we got [ __ ] this podcast tonight is
sponsored by tracker and Anat calm those
bad [ __ ] I also got new
paperwork you score big throw old [ __ ]
away
and that's it man we're gonna start this
podcast
you
then a little skinny ones they all come
all this is in the same case I don't
know why she walked away from me excuse
me Carter because if you told a handful
catch ya she should've got you handful
catch have you told them why would paste
this isn't got you wallet faces you
shouldn't had a cheese man they don't
come with cheese's restroom you got like
the dumbest Spanish chicken
let's get a little water watering down
the pallets so we get ready to be a big
little reason they don't want never
killed nobody
I want to be good today you got it
he's got everything I'll be back in a
few minutes get ready to rock
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happening now on YouTube